do you ever
to this day
sometimes get lost in thoughts of the
past and remember that little girl who
was picked on and does it cause you to
be emotional or do you have you kind of
I tried my husband I tried to watch that
Bo Burnham movie eighth grade I got
about 20 minutes into it and just like
fell into like ancient heaving sobs that
I couldn't I don't think I could act
um because they were so deep you know
and and to get on with your life you do
a lot of things to sort of save yourself
and
um I'm still to this day trying to get
over the coping mechanisms that I used
um
so you know yeah we we stopped that
movie I don't know I don't know if I'll
ever be able to finish it but I I kind
of know it's the greatest movie ever
made because it were there do you
remember names do you remember certain
girls or boys you like you could riff
them off you just rip you know go you
because I could do that too because I
was picked on a little bit too and I was
the shortest kid in my high school and
um
but I could remember names I can
remember names I could say names right
now I'm not gonna say because they're so
specific it's very specific you know
it's like if I said Raleigh Johnson
he didn't pick on me though but I also
like it was also like I said it was a
mop it was everyone and so there's
there's that but there's also just this
kind of like
cloud of energy in a way that I remember
more than anything
[Music]
um
because it was you know it was a smaller
school and so everybody kind of got on
the same page I remember my mom saying
something she was like oh he's always so
proud of you you always made friends
with the new girl
and I was like oh that's because you
don't know that she was the only person
who would talk to me because she didn't
know yet and about two weeks after that
she would no longer I remember that
happened when I was
I was a sophomore and there was a new
Fresh couple freshmen that came in and
I I knew these guys were going to be
popular yeah they were like good looking
guys and they were like you know
athletes and I remember becoming sort of
friends with them
and hanging out with them and remember
it was for like a couple of weeks until
they caught on that I'm I'm not popular
I'm not I'm not what you thought and it
was like crazy how much that matters
when you're that age did you get did
things change when you went to high
school so yes I ended up my coping
mechanism at first was just to shut up I
just stopped talking I stopped I just
was the invisible person that they would
have preferred me to be
um I mean I spoke in class and I spoke
at home but I just I just didn't try to
be social with anyone any longer
um and then honestly I started doing the
plays and that was the only place that I
talked
um how did you get I guess since you
loved dancing in the hallways and all
that I had always loved theater and
things like that so I was like all right
let's give this a shot
I had always danced and
did some singing and things like that so
I I
did that I did a couple of plays and
something in there around eighth grade I
did Guys and Dolls Junior and I remember
like walking into the cafeteria and
seeing the like place that I normally
went and sat alone and then seeing the
place where all the kids that I had done
the show with were sitting and I
remember like very distinctly taking
that
deep breath and deciding to go sit with
them
um and that kind of shifted things and I
I still
it took me years and years
and probably I'm still not done figuring
out how to just like let myself be me
right
um because that still feels like such a
a dangerous thing to do
since that's what got me you know
humiliated so often I know how you feel
I really know what it's like to
I I've talked about it about becoming an
actor because of that like I didn't have
I've said it how many times have I said
so I didn't have to be me yeah and then
I got lost somewhere along the way
between who I really was and who I
thought I was yeah and then all of a
sudden you get older
and you realize
I don't know exactly who I am